all right I am going live a little bit
early because I looked in here and
there's a lot of questions already
piling up and speaking of something
piling up I've got my lamp filled up
with our cat sassy so that's why the
view point is a little bit different
perhaps for for this one so let me see
if I can adjust things to get the
lighting a little bit better there we go
so let's just jump in and start taking
some questions for this first am a
session of 2020 andrew says I know
you've been through depression seeking a
professional help some of the resources
come from philosophy as self-study
possible I'm embarrassed to admit I feel
low to a professional yeah I mean it's
it's helpful to go to professionals not
all professionals are of the same
caliber and I would say in in my case
it's complicated by the fact that over
the course of my studies I learned a lot
of you know psychological theory and so
you know like somebody's gonna do CBT
with me I know what they're usually
before they start in on it and a lot of
therapists you know therapists are like
everything else there's some who are
really brilliant somewhere really
insightful and and can relate to people
according well and are secure in their
own competence and then there's plenty
who are at the exact opposite extreme
yes he's got that matching move this you
know where they there's an acrid
therapists at all and then there's some
in the middle and you have to be very
pragmatic about that you know it's if
you in some cases depending on how mild
the depression that you're working with
is or how severe where in between you
might be able to get by without dealing
with with professional counselor or
therapist but there's nothing wrong with
going to somebody and it can be quite
helpful and there are a lot of resources
in philosophy but you have to know where
to go with them and I think that people
who put them forward are also kind of a
mixed bag as well some of them will
probably not be all that helpful and you
know when I when I can find good
professional help I seek it out there's
no reason why I wouldn't want to go to
somebody who I can have a useful
dialogue with and get insight from
difficult to find people that that work
out for me all right
Barnhart I've got a very simple answer
to this I'd like to hear what you think
about the allows and allows Union
mysteries I don't think anything at them
I don't pay any attention to that sort
of sort of thing really I don't I don't
you know think that we understand Plato
by reference to them you know I'm not an
SOT I'm not an esotericist so they're
interesting just like everything in the
flock the history of religion is
interesting but they're just a little
tiny blip in it they're not the key to
anything vintage vodka what do you make
of the foundationalism versus coherent
ism debate in epistemology I don't
because I don't do analytic epistemology
and that's essentially coming out of
analytic philosophy so it doesn't
doesn't really have that that much that
that's of interest to me you know my
time is rather limited
I mean I'll say this I think
foundationalism as a very broad project
is interesting but has ultimately failed
but I don't think that you know
something that what we want to call
coherent ISM is going to be necessarily
the only alternative to it as if it was
a new you know providing a new
foundation Ernest says can you offer a
resource that best describes a
difference between the Republic of
trumps 21st century administration and
Lincoln's 19th cent
a Republican administration thanks no I
can't offer any resources because I'm
not that's not my area work I'm sure
that you can easily google that and I
mean there's so many differences the
Republicans are even the Republicans of
just ten years ago are not the
Republicans of today except for maybe
some of the you know most wacked-out Tea
Party enthusiasts who now have
essentially you know become the party
along with this cult of personality
around their their leader it the word
Republican is it's an equivocation to
talk about the current Republican
administration as being in any way
remotely like that of Lincoln Lincoln
would be turning over in his grave
looking at this sort of thing you know
so there's there's plenty of features we
could just talk about racism one prime
example so but we don't have to go on
with that Karl bod any advice on a good
starting point for Isaiah Berlin and any
advice for reading his work in general
because he's not somebody who I like
read my way through I've read a few of
his essays but I haven't read a lot of
Berlin usually the one that probably
gets read the most was the one about
negative and positive Liberty so I would
I would check that out that you can
easily find online in a PDF I know
because I let a student through it in a
tutorial about a year and a half ago
I mean Berlin is is an interesting
figure which had more time to to check
him out but probably find the time to do
it except when it coincides with
something that I'm interested in
Bala asks what's your view about Indian
philosophy well my view about Indian
philosophy is that you can't have a view
about Indian philosophy
because it's as rich and deep of a
tradition as his Chinese philosophy as
his Western philosophy so it's sort of
like saying what do you think about
Western philosophy oh I am for it you
know you know you got to get a little
bit more granular with that it certainly
deserves to be studied and taken
seriously and but you you you know in
order to do it well just as if you you
know you want to study Descartes you
really need to know some French and some
Latin if you want to be like a scholar
that's it's the same sort of issue with
with Indian philosophy Sanskrit is kind
of a must right or if you can study
Buddhism there's a whole series of
languages that you'd want to study so
you know I'm not a specialist I've
taught some pieces of Indian philosophy
but I you know it's not not an area of
my particular expertise getting a lot of
people asking about things they're not
really within my wheel well oh here's a
good follow-up Quintin pasca how much do
you think reading in the original
language assists in understanding a
philosopher writer it depends on the
philosopher so you know we're fortunate
at least in the english-speaking world
in that we do have a lot of good
translations out there that we're done
in the 20th and early 21st century and
you know you you're probably missing
some things but you're probably not
missing that much with many thinkers by
just reading English translation but you
know you never really know until you
read in the original I can tell you that
with with some thinkers and some
languages just because of the nature of
what it is if they're they're looking at
in the text that they left behind it can
be incredibly advantageous to be able to
read say classical Greek Aristotle is a
prime example so one reason why I got so
excited about
researching Aristotle and anger back in
the late 1990s and then continuing on
through into the 2000s was that I was
reading Aristotle's works and not not
particularly for looking at anger but I
was reading you know that the two ethics
the politics the topics and the rhetoric
and I noticed that the same terms were
coming up and being discussed and being
translated differently in different
texts different English translations and
so I was like wow they're the you know
if you were only armed with English
you'd never know that he's actually
discussing the same phenomena here so I
think that was kind of you know an
important realization for me so it can
be quite helpful you know and you know
like if you're studying say Aquinas and
you're using the Blackfriars translation
and you're looking at the treatise on
the emotions which was done by Toni
Kenny who is a hardcore analytic
philosopher very interested in the
topics of his time you can you can see
that the translation is bearing those
imprints of his interest and sometimes
he's off so being able to read the Latin
is quite useful but you know you have to
decide how much of your time you want to
invest in it it's not like it sound like
you can just like you know listen to
some language tapes or something like
that and then go to a philosophical text
and be able to to read it so six what
philosopher to read after Hegel well
whoever you want there is no set order
in which you have to read philosophy and
does nature believe science is a fraud
no he doesn't believe science is a fraud
he believes that science reveals to us
that science itself as a sort of project
sort of science or the capital s
undercuts its own foundations
and shows us that it's as arbitrary a
way of doing things as so many others
that doesn't make it a fraud doesn't
mean you can't make gunpowder or you
know if you were around today produce
very complex computer science algorithms
to aid the study of you know theorems
and mathematics but you know he's not
interested in just fact but in value you
know science would put itself out as a
project that gave new meaning to things
after I think about positivism right
yeah thing about compte and positivism
first you have a theological phase that
a metaphysical phase then a positive
science phase and positive science will
solve everything because it's no longer
you know making these crazy theological
assumptions and it's no longer making
these metaphysical assumptions
well nietzsche points out that that's
not the man of science is just as much a
theologian as as a theologian so you
know i think he's right about that
actually they'll ask any thought on
theistic personal ISM versus classical
theism can I explain the difference
classical theism is a category made up
in the 20th century that doesn't
actually correspond to much of anything
I'm not a big believer in using isms as
buckets to put things in as you can
probably tell from the you know question
about foundationalism versus coherent
ISM you gotta you gotta you gotta
articulate a scheme and say okay this
person's think I mean Ansem has been
read as a personal list right I actually
have an article myself but he's also
read as a classical theists these are
these are just categories that people
use to kind of make you know to make
sense out of things but there's no
substitute for actually like engaging
with thinkers in a deep way and anytime
you do these these isms lose their their
you could call them clasificado efficacy
so alright tjf what do you think about
philosophy of religion designated the
theology and religious studies
departments at universities that
actually have them I'm at NYU and
analytic philosophy reigns supreme here
yeah if you can't get good philosophy of
religion in a philosophy department why
not get it somewhere else just like if
you want to read to Tocqueville you're
not going to read democracy in America
and a philosophy department most likely
you're going to read it in a political
science department or American Studies
department a lot of philosophy gets done
outside of philosophy departments
precisely because many philosophy
departments became very very narrow and
their specialization and the breadth of
what they were going to look at so you
know and you can do philosophy of
religion well outside of philosophy and
you can do it poorly it really depends
on who you're reading and who the
professors are and you know what they
want to do
Matthew Lowrey wondering if you've read
to lose yes of course I've talked about
this many times and if you have any
thoughts I would love to see you do a
course on difference and repetition or
anti Oedipus well if you want to see me
do a course on something and I'm not
already doing it then you know what
people do is Commission videos and you
know if you want to do that sort of
thing you can email me about that
otherwise people get what I'm currently
working on anti Oedipus is not to lose
the anti Oedipus is to lose in qatari
and I as I said many times a much more
interest in what the lose does on his
own than what he does with with qatari
because I think that he's a better
thinker on his own he thought the
opposite but I think he was right about
that
so you know what are you gonna do you
know Garrett Paul what are my thoughts
on Baudrillard very interesting thinker
if
that you know the category of the
hyperreal is not something radically new
in his thought there were other people
that were talking about similar things
and similar sort of swallowing up of
meaning and a sort of coming unmoored
from genuine you know reference long
before a board yard including Plato
right and but many others throughout the
history of philosophy but I think
Baudrillard is well worth worth checking
out and reading I find him quite
interesting so Julian is it advisable to
attempt to separate Nietzsche's life
from his philosophical positions does
this method of interpretation do justice
to his philosophy yeah of course
you should always be able to separate a
philosophers ideas and works from their
biography and then you should be able to
put them back together these are not you
know paths the diverge in a frosty and
forest where once you take one of them
you know you're stuck on it for life and
that makes all the difference and go
back and forth there is there some
instances where I think it's quite
useful to know some things about
Nietzsche's biography or you know in des
cartes case and know some things about
his biography this is you know part of
what history of philosophy is about it's
not just about reading attacks in
isolation it's reading them within a
context but you don't want to try to
simply reduce philosophy to biography
even though Nietzsche himself does that
sometimes with his predecessors so you
know and whether you're doing justice to
Nietzsche's philosophy I think that's
much more a factor of how you read it
and how much you read and what you do
with it you know you can you can do it
from either of those perspectives all
right uh Carola was easy I loved your
conversation regarding Camus and
I'm not sure which conversation that is
but if you like to them I'm glad so
maybe that was maybe that was that one
of the ones from when I was doing those
library talks back in Kingston Brad what
do you think of conspiracy theory and
how it relates to epistemology there
seems to be a lot in the political
sphere so I don't know that there's any
such thing as conspiracy theory and the
singular as like a Platonic ideal or
something out there there's I'm sure
there's somebody who calls what they do
conspiracy theory but I don't I don't I
don't know that sort of thing there's
plenty of conspiracy theories and pistol
ology if it's doing its job ought to be
tackling the prevalence of them and and
you know looking at some of them and
saying well this is this is BS and this
is this is something maybe there's
actually some legs to this and you got
to look at conspiracy theories in there
their substance I guess you could talk
also about like the conspiracy theorist
as a type but I suspect that there isn't
just one single psychological type that
helps us to conceptualize and explain
what's going on and people buy into
conspiracy theories and you know we
should you know conspiracy theories sort
of morph into large-scale ideologies as
well I mean think about all the crazy
nonsense that was written from say the
mid 18th century all the way through to
you know basically up to the present
about race and you know the races of
humankind and all this this craziness
that you you see people you know bought
into that they used it as the lens to
make sense of things there were always
critics by the way pointing out this is
nonsense you know what
they were Maurice Blondell and
Pottsville Yamani today or Jacques
Barzun you know later on in the late
20th century people have always been
like yeah that this doesn't add up but
you know things like that can be quite
popular and you know we can we can
easily imagine something like queue and
on you know becoming mainstreamed and
people you know like millions of people
buying into it doesn't make any of it
right all right
zero zero for a fee what do you think
the dangers are being a reductionist
materialist or naturalist and what is
the appeal of this sort of philosophy
outside of just scientism or science the
appeal it's a good question I mean again
I don't think that there's a single
etiology you know a study of causes that
that relates to that some people some
people come from say a conservative
Christian background where they're
encouraged to be cultural Crusaders and
then they you know find out that the
earth is not five million or five five
thousand years old and you know they
like swing over to another extreme and
they become Crusaders of secularism or
something like that like what you're
calling scientism here and that's that's
a set of causes but that's not everybody
you know others get into it because they
have a desire for having some absolute
grounding that they can place things on
some some do it because they just want
to be jerks everybody else I'd say the
you know I [ __ ] love science crowd
from the you know the mid-2010 a lot of
the people were basically you know like
that and I think some people genuinely
think that it's it's the best way of
understanding things
I always find the materialists who
aren't reductive I mean in a certain way
everybody everybody's reductive you know
but it's a question of how much you
actually allow into your ontology or
even not an ontology necessarily but
your engagement with with things you
know a great example of this George
Santayana right he is a thoroughgoing
materialist he still thinks that you
need to be able to discuss things like
spirit William James is kind of like
that too right although James is much
more committed to open pluralism I would
say you know the Stoics had no problem
talking about a soul even though they
were hardcore materialists matter of
fact neither did the Epicureans
Epicureans even had gods they gods just
didn't care about human beings so
alright Mick de facto what do you think
about what is chronologically first and
ontologically first is a difference
between mythology and philosophy I think
that sounds too simple so I probably
wouldn't go about it that way
why says how would a virtue ethicist
approach the issue of capital punishment
it's plenty of virtue ethicists out
there that you can read talking about
that including aristotle if you're
asking like how would they approach it
in the present you know given like our
current system like for example I think
that myself in some cases capital
punishment could not only be warranted
on you know grounds of incapacitation
but but I see something - something of
value - retribution for particularly
heinous crimes but given that it takes
us about 20 years to actually bring off
an a capital sentence it becomes
inhumane and the
process you know so yeah I think virtue
ethicists are not are unlikely unless
they've already got some sort of really
deep commitment say to like some
absolute value to all life or something
along those lines
they're probably going to look at things
on a case-by-case in situation by
situation basis so they'd be incredibly
concerned that whatever sentences are
meted out be just and that there be you
know as little corruption within the
system as possible so again our our
system you know if you want to call it
that given that we have we don't even
have like a federal system of justice we
have all this patchwork of states and
municipalities all kind of doing their
own thing and then we have like you know
sort of court systems that you can
appeal to but it's incredibly difficult
to do that I think most virtue ethicists
would probably say that you know the
current system we have is quite unjust
right Montu vibes are perceptions
intrinsic in the grand scheme or are
they relative to human experiences well
I mean we think that animals perceive
things and even plants register things
in some way because they respond to
their environment so I guess we could
say that life is perceptive living
things are perceptive the things that we
talk about perceiving like you know
perceiving this as a water bottle and
you know registering that maybe I ought
to go fill it up so it's all the way or
something along those lines viewing it
as empty or full you know maybe that's
distinctively human there maybe not you
know I mean it's not as if chimpanzee
can't realize that the bottle needs to
go be filled up and you know if they had
hands dolphins probably good too right
if they cared about water bottles so you
know I wouldn't
it's merely relative to human beings but
you know the experiences that we do have
play a major role in providing the
context that that our perceptions take
place in and get labeled as as what they
are you know all right um
flash oh lord what did Stoics think of
the gladiators and ancient boxers as I
understand Romans saw the Colosseum as a
way to display Roman virtues and Klan
thieves as a boxer but Marcus Aurelius
disapproved well the Colosseum was not a
place to display Roman virtues that's
that's [ __ ] very you know it was
people were there to Massacre each other
for the entertainment of the crowds
gladiators were despised for the most
part later on you know they had kind of
a following but it was you know it's
it's the sort of following that people
have of something that's that's
essentially disreputable so whoever told
you that it's that that it was primarily
about a way to display Roman virtues
that they're if they're full of it and
it's probably some alrighty
you know website or something like that
that are into bro ISM rather than
stoicism um you know the Stoics didn't
think that that gladiatorial contests
are particularly good boxing you know
boxing was done not in a gladiatorial
contests but in a different context of
the games you know these were not slaves
or war captives these were free people
who were willingly entering in to do it
that makes a huge difference so yeah and
clam face was a boxer but you know
certainly wasn't all he was right he
also carried water for a profession
Lucca Oh what works would you recommend
to a physicalist to make them doubt
their position I don't know there isn't
any one single thing where if somebody
is a devoted physicalist you know
thinking that all there is
okay let's just say MIT materialist
right that you're gonna get them beyond
that I don't think people have genuinely
change their philosophical positions
because they encounter some perfect
argument that says oh you know you've
got this wrong it's rather they have to
become aware of the inadequacy of their
their own way of looking at things and
there's so many different ways that that
can happen all right
bound to vibe Stoics for gladiators and
vice versa no I wouldn't say that's
that's true
some Stoics were stuck being gladiators
no doubt but we don't know of any and
gladiators were not stoic in any sense
connected to the philosophy by a virtue
of being gladiators John Halliwell I'm a
physics and electrical engineering major
working through platonic dialogues and
your lectures what philosophers should I
move on to so I can closer relate
philosophy to the hard sciences I don't
know I mean pick people who actually
have something to say I guess about the
physical world you know like Descartes
or bacon or you know even though it's
physics is totally outmoded Aristotle
there's tons and tons of people you
could read is supposed to be Hobbes has
his own weird weird physics of sorts he
basically subsumes ethics in is to be
something like a branch of physics in
his view so you know there's so many
different people that you could you
could choose I'm not a philosophy of
science person so
you know you might want to ask somebody
if you want something that's that's
really really close to like
consideration of the the Natural
Sciences
I would I would ask somebody in that
field
Kyocera says Happy New Year Happy New
Year to you yeah I'm happy New Year to
everybody hopefully this will be a good
one for us Corolla is easy if you can
tell some more information about the
absurd person how can we notice our life
is absurd at the moment I live but I'm
not sure it's if it's absurd or not
what's the sign of it absurd man so
you've probably referencing cow Moo
there I would read the myth of synthesis
right because he discusses it at
considerable length in there what the
experience of the absurd is like and how
easily it can happen it's not something
to be forced and the absurd is not not
something that qualifies a life or a
life itself
the absurd for him is the divorce
between the human being their desires of
rationality and the world that they live
it
the absurdity says is a third term it's
not something that just describes the
world or their their life Williams end
any advice on reading the philosophy of
language and epistemology for
self-directed learners sure start with
Plato there's a whole dialogue called
the Cratylus that's you know one of the
earliest works in the philosophy of
language and then continue on through
there's lots and lots of works you can
encounter along the way if you want to
skip a bit you know maybe reading
Umberto eCos books is a good way to do
it because echo is a semiotician who
understands the classic tradition
understands contemporary stuff in in
European philosophy understands what
analytic philosophers are doing and in
his his own interesting sticks you know
he's got books like semiotics on the fly
the philosophy of language and theory of
semiotic so those are good good starting
points but there's so much discussion of
language throughout history that it's
it's well
earth you know digging into people along
the way
pistol' mala ji you know again start
with Plato there's a lot of epistemology
and his stuff there's some stuff in
Aristotle there's you get the stoic
epistemology largely through through
Cicero's on the academics I would say
also discusses the Epicureans as well
we've lost a lot of their works and you
know there's there's all these thinkers
throughout the history of philosophy I
mean or you can if you want to even jump
into contemporary analytic epistemology
you might find it rather dry and boring
but some people really get into that
there's all sorts of people that you can
check out cancer what do you think are
the most fundamental divides between
left and right wing politics I don't
know there's so many different issues
and I don't think that there is a neat
clasificado a thing of left and right
you know there's there's some things
that traditionally have been seen as as
right and they can become left you know
and vice versa I would say that in some
respects one of the one of the parts of
the spectrum that gets left out is
actually living up to their ideals or
totally corrupt and interested it only
in a holy hunting power right which
doesn't map on to like the authoritarian
- libertarian thing because libertarians
can be just as corrupt as anybody else
and authoritarian can actually be quite
quite devoted to their their causes so I
don't know I mean there's there's
probably plenty of websites out there
that you can you can look at that'll
give you a breakdown of what's
considered traditionally left and right
in our presence
earnest rights I think philosophies are
behind all of the dichotomies of
politics for example Adam Smith in the
ekend
even Bo HM implicit theories of cultural
development yeah there's something to
that every every politics involves some
sort of reference to philosophy it might
be crap philosophy but it encompasses
some sort of philosophy and then you
know you can look at political movements
which are always kind of a you know a
mess they're never everybody all being
on the same page and you can you know
you can see like different things
playing themselves out in in that as
well so you know there are people who
would blanch at being called
utilitarians but they really are
utilitarians just for their particular
group or party or you know tribe or
whatever it's going to be so alright
david has a question that I I don't know
I haven't thought about any of this
stuff for years yes I wouldn't know I'm
in red Gettier cookie for four since I
was in grad school you think getting
your cases fail in reference to Kripke
and semantics are they simply cases this
is semantic failure I don't know that's
something for an analytic philosopher I
found Kripke incredibly mind-numbingly
dull when I read him and you know read
my way through the things that I had to
read and left him behind after that so I
do recall thinking that well they use
semantics in an interesting way because
it's a little it doesn't quite encompass
what what we often talk about that way
but I don't know you'd have to ask
somebody else who is much more
interested in that Luka do you think
artificial intelligence can ever have
consciousness if it doesn't it's not
artificial intelligence it's just
mimicking human intelligence or
parasitically playing off of human
intelligence right so but do we think
that some of the things that we call a
IR Bergen ham
consciousness which would include
presumably not just awareness of other
things but also awareness of themselves
and references so it would include
self-consciousness to a certain degree I
don't know that that's why that's a
tough one
lots of sci-fi stuff has has artificial
intelligence in that way but I'm not
seeing anything that makes me think that
that's going to happen and I lived
through you could say several
generations of discourses about this
this sort of thing where you know the
next new thing was going to be the step
that would bring about genuine
artificial intelligence you know and
I've seen I've seen people go down dead
ends like you know expert systems in the
80s and 90s we're gonna be like
artificial intelligence and now it's all
about neural nets but when you look at
it you're like it's not really
intelligence as such you know machine
learning isn't really learning I mean
it's interesting artificial intelligence
the whole discourse about it tells us
way more about human beings and has to
do way more with human emotions and
desires and conceptualizations of things
and cultural constructs than it does
with the the machines that were
revealing and a long time ago back in
the late 80s I started talking you know
cuz I had friends who were really into
these these sort of topics and
discourses I said you know artificial
intelligence if it ever does exist we
should quit thinking of it as like
something that would be separate from a
human being and then you know maybe
replace a human being we should
understand it rather as interfaces
between human subjects or human subjects
in themselves that takes a lot of the
heavy weight loss because whatever spark
of you know subjectivity you're gonna
you're gonna get well you get that from
the humans now of course that means
you're not going to get like replicas or
things like that but it
it sure does simplify matters for the
kinds of systems that we often engage
with so you know I think that that we
can hit them if consciousness includes
self consciousness I don't see getting
that out of the sort of systems that we
have that presence as a matter of fact I
was talking about this with somebody
else the other day Siri seems to have
gotten stupider over the last several
years we turned on Syria and tried using
it for things and that's supposed to be
you know like a not a cutting-edge AI
but you know a virtual personal
assistance so doesn't make me all that
optimistic about it
Laura Dawson Tony can anyone refute the
maxim all human beings are animals that
are conscious if not then can we build
any deductive claim from it that sounds
like a big note non-starter to me I
don't know where this is coming from I
wouldn't call it a maxim i would just
call it a statement all human beings are
animals that are conscious while animals
are conscious quite often so not all
human beings are conscious all the time
so but building deductive claims from it
I don't know that's not really how I
think about doing philosophy building
deductive claims Kim Sarah do you
recommend a particular translation of
the enchiridion no not really
I mean I I actually like older
translations but a lot of people want
more modern ones just be aware that you
know some of the ones that are out there
are more paraphrases than sticking to
the text itself and so you know you make
a choice for something that's more
readable you might actually be taking
yourself away from what he's saying but
and if you're going to read the end
creating you really should read the
discourses anyway
the enchiridion should not be sort of a
stopping point for for things but I'm
sure there's plenty of good translations
out there I mean when I when I work I
usually provide my own translations but
my translations are you know partly
indebted to the translations of others
that have them human evolution in which
ways do you prefer Aristotle to the
Stoics well you know I think the Stoics
notion of virtue and vice being sort of
like an on/off switch is interesting and
I do intend to do some writing about
that but I think they're fundamentally
wrong with that and you know we see
Cicero trying to make sense of that and
we see we see at Epictetus essentially
not not talking much about virtue but
rather about other other things and
acknowledging that there has to be sort
of progress in things and we see Seneca
backs like this at the Sun degree I
think the Aristotelian account of virtue
is probably you know as a mean between
extremes involving a bunch of different
rites host day you know in Greek and
there being something in between virtue
and vice namely and Katya and Achrafieh
I think that that's that's probably
right and you also see by the way middle
and neoplatonist taking up those
Aristotelian concepts and and bringing
them in to supplement what Plato has to
say because they recognize that that's
probably right
I don't I'm not attracted particularly
to calling things indifference I think
Cicero is right in his criticism of
saying you know these these are goods
and Bad's there
not the good and the bad what else you
know when it comes to the emotions I
think the Stoics have a lot of really
really useful techniques to bring to
bear on anger but I'm more Aristotelian
when it comes to that which by the way
it also is is you know rational emotive
behavior therapy Alice thought that
there was a good kind of anger he
doesn't be very very careful with anger
the Stoics made improvements on the
Aristotelian logic so they're the stoic
certainly have an edge both the Stoics
and the Aristotelian I think we're wrong
about the nature of the heavens of the
universe but their their stuff was very
interesting I mean they have much more
in common than they disagree about as do
the plate mists they had you know
they're all virtue ethicist they all
think that self analysis is incredibly
important and working on our habits is
incredibly important so I you know I I
don't see that much as they say daylight
between between the two uh genre hi
professor what do you think of about
linguistic studies contribution to
philosophy as in fair nan de Saussure in
a semiotic triangle this will serve as
great pioneer one of the things I really
like about this so sir he says it's
really early on in the quarter that we
seek to Generale is if you want to
understand linguistics and I think this
goes for anybody's doing philosophy of
language you need to know multiple
languages you need to have some basis
for comparison and not just know them in
a purely academic I took a few courses
sense but actually you know use them and
read in them and maybe even dream in
them I think he was totally right about
that and there have been so many people
when I was doing philosophy of language
as sort of a specialization
they'd only know English and I'd be like
you I mean you can't even read Vidkun
Stein other than the translations that
we have and see whether the translations
are right and understand that you know
the this there aren't great differences
between German and English but there are
some that that matter you know you have
no basis for comparison whatsoever I
think just so sir who knew a slew of
languages is is quite correct about that
and you know his conception of the sign
a signifier signified you know and then
the sign function that's a brilliant
idea
people other people you know like Jakob
s'en and Hilton's love and even roll on
Bart's made great capital out of that I
do think that that Umberto Eco is is
right to try to take purses triadic
conception of the sign which includes an
intra pratense and map it on to to the
disso serie and essentially binary sign
is is really a great great idea so yeah
I think I think people should read this
so sir
but then you know be prepared to get go
beyond oh and I'll mention another great
structuralist that I really like AJ grow
mas really interesting stuff that they
got out of that that basis so zarbor the
Greek what is the future of philosophy
do you think someone like Plato or can't
is coming
I think there's right now there's you
know so many different balls in the air
and so many different things going on
that there wouldn't be a figure who
would be so absolutely central we should
remember though that Kant was not as
central as we often make him out to be
it's not like you know he's very
important in German thought less so in
English and French thought as far as I
can tell had had no influence at all on
like Spanish and Portuguese you know
Italian developments in the 19th century
other than imports
again had some some importance for
American thought but it's not like all
philosophy had to go through cut you
know but I you know I think where is
philosophy going it's gonna spill as it
is right now far outside of the Academy
and I think academic philosophy will be
about as important as it was in late
antiquity where you know there were some
places like Alexandria where clearly you
know people were engaging with each
other in a way that was kind of like
academic philosophy and interesting
things came out of that but also people
doing their own thing outside of that
making use of the resources of
philosophy that have been developed
throughout the centuries you know they
did some of the more interesting stuff
and you know if you also if you look at
the history of philosophy philosophy
does best when it's not done in a vacuum
by people who are specialists solely in
philosophy so you know you want you want
people who actually have an interest in
politics or history or medicine or
mathematics or technology trends or
things like that that's that's that's
important Dimitra do you think hood
roles work allows for or entails
idealism as some have suggested allows
for sure you can read his role as an
idealist I don't know how you'd read the
later of us role as an idealist you know
but I suppose if you stick with the
early stuff you know maybe maybe that's
the case but I don't see idealism as a
terrible thing you know bond to vibes is
objectivism stoicism 2.0 or an offshoot
has nothing to do whatsoever with
stoicism Ryan Randy and objectivism Rand
would have
hated the modern stoic movement so I
don't think that there's any connection
for ran the great hero of philosophy was
an Aristotle who never existed because
you look at her history of philosophy
stuff it's so terrible that you know
you're you you even if you like any of
the other stuff you you you if you know
anything about the history of philosophy
and you read the things that she says
you got over kind of rolling your eyes
at it so Troy and Muller should I avoid
critical theory why would you avoid
anything that that people find
interesting I mean I don't know who
gives you that idea
critical theory too by the way means two
different things there's the Frankfurt
School critical theory you know we're
talking about Horkheimer Adorno all
ultimately leading up to to harm us
including maracuja and erich fromm I'm
away well it's actually continued on
past time Baba's with you know Axl Hana
than people like that and that's pretty
rigorous philosophy well if you've ever
read a door know he is one of the most
difficult
philosophers to read and also if you
understand all the references very
rewarding and why would you spare
yourself the you know task of trying to
make sense out of that sort of stuff and
then there's critical theory in a
different sense that it's sort of wide
you know spectrum of people who say that
they're doing critique or you know
criticism of things and that there's a
lot of crap in that but there's a lot of
crap in most philosophical movements and
cultural movements and that's where you
know you get all sorts of that you get
like you know what is the flavor of the
month sort of thing but a lot of its
worth reading I don't know why you would
wanted to skip it Anthony victory
thoughts on Maryland Westphal don't
really have any it's been a very long
time since I've read him
[Music]
wait a lot of people making the same
comment over and over and over again ah
Bruce is here thanks Bruce
it's my thing scrolled up now I need to
to get into this and the thing is the
live chat is kinda there's so much stuff
in here that it's not showing me stuff
further up so I may be skipping over
some one ardilla but have I ever done
have I ever or do I ever plan on
studying mere little Ponty
I took a whole graduate seminar in
Merrell upon tea in graduate school
what's my opinion on the phenomenology
of perception interesting book you know
I did some writing on it never published
any of it
I like Marilyn Ponte I like his notion
of like normal perception as being like
an intersection of all these different
things going on at the same time and
that when things break down that's when
we get the weird stuff popping up that
you can understand through a sort of
reductivism and I like his discussion of
the live body I think that that's
important so Zulu nation I'm currently
reading the Republic on my own for the
first time what are some things I should
be aware of could go over my head not
studying it from an academic sense
greetings from Germany
well yeah that's a good question it is a
dialogue and the characters in the
dialogue represents not just their their
positions but the way of articulating
their position so through Symmachus
comes out swinging so to speak right but
then he sticks around and he comes up
again in book six Socrates says they've
now become friends
Glaucon and ana mantas are they want to
hear the best position for for justice
and they're going to
argue against it even though they don't
believe in it themselves
pol marcus is endorsing this traditional
you know friends vs. enemy distinction
early on and Socrates himself is
spelling out a ideal Republic that will
never exist you know people like Karl
Popper essentially misread Plato
probably deliberately you know in order
to say well he's putting out this
totalitarian society as his blueprint
for everything
I mean Socrates doesn't think that this
is a realizable goal you know so it's a
much more problematic work than
programmatic work even though it looks
much more programmatic
and another thing I'll say too there is
considerable commentary after Plato dies
going on for centuries about some of the
key ideas that are going on in there so
like Plutarch for example is going to
take up Plato you know and then he's a
middle plainest and other middle Plato's
like Al quinoa's you know
then the neoplatonist will take up Plato
as well and sometimes they will go
further with the ideas than Plato
himself was able to do in that that text
so I think those are those are good
things to do and the other thing I would
suggest to is man don't try to read it
all at one one sitting you know one slog
you don't know it's it's a complex text
it's perfectly fine just to like read
one book of it a day you know there's
ten books to the work what we nowadays
would call chapters books because they
were Scrolls that's how much you could
fit on a scroll so but it's it's you
know it's a great work and don't expect
to understand all of it necessarily
immediately right that that's another
thing with playdough
well right Jin Stampede writes hello dr.
zedler and all present in the chat may I
ask if you consider it morally correct
to enjoy artistic works by despicable
people can should we separate art from
the artist you don't have to necessarily
separate art from the artist to enjoy
artistic works by despicable people
I don't consider Lovecraft himself
despicable I consider his racism
despicable but I don't consider him as a
whole
despicable right so yeah we can do that
I mean I think there's some cases it's
kind of an interesting thing to think
about with canceled culture right
there's this tendency to say if we find
anything wrong with a person screw all
their stuff you know well and that's
been going on by the way that's not a
new that canceled culture on Twitter's a
new thing but I remember that being
suggested back in the 90s when I was an
undergraduate in a kind of you know back
back in the woods kind of college so it
was not a hotbed of radicalism but there
was a lot of you know like well if this
person did this we shouldn't read their
works and I was most of the time I was
like yours lazy I don't want to read
their works you know and that was
probably the case for many my fellow
students you know we do have to be able
to to assess this stuff separately you
know a lot of this comes up to like yeah
you know people in the ancient world
they didn't reject slavery I mean there
were some actual projections Aristotle's
conception of the natural slave was not
what what slaveholders made it into
later on Aristotle actually thought that
you know most slaves were slaves by
force rather than by nature but you
don't say oh well we get rid of
Aristotle that can't be any good you you
see whether there's resources and that
person's ideas to going
you know alright one ardilla
asks he's he's reading this chant right
yeah of course I am sometimes it takes
me a long time given how many things
there are to get down to individuals
things Marty what's your take on the
phenomenology of spirit being a
requirement for the logic to the logic
or can it stand alone like Holgate
things science and logic we're talking
about not the encyclopedia logic yeah I
think I can stand alone I mean there's
and with with your follow up questions
there's standalone as we can understand
it and then there's like standalone as
like it's an impenetrable Fortress of
philosophy that can stand up to any
attack I mean I don't think any
philosophy book can do that but you read
it not you know I don't think that you
read Hegel's logic for the absolute
totality of the system I don't know many
people would do that but do you read it
because there's interesting things in it
that says about things like the issue of
the limit or his you know
reinterpretation of the syllogism stuff
like that alright um Bhoja dar asks
what's my opinion on Nietzsche's will to
power that's an interesting concept
central the Nietzsche's work I think
he's right to some some degree that
there is something like will to power
within everything that has life I don't
think that that's everything that we
have but ghin Stampede has a very
interesting observation here I don't
know if I should congratulate you for
having trolls in the chat for the last
few AMA streams it means your channels
growing so I guess that's ultimately a
good thing I mean ideally in a perfect
world you have no trolls trolls are
usually people who are kind of you know
they haven't figured out how not to be a
screw-up in their life at this point in
time the idea of jumping in just just
you know
stir the pot or something like that
that's an adolescent point of view and
comportment and you know I mean I I was
there a long long time ago myself so I
understand that and and it took other
people who were older than me eventually
saying hey act like an [ __ ] get
treated like an [ __ ] for me to
realize that that wasn't really what I
wanted that I actually didn't want to
you know fit in somehow and you know
have connections with other people that
were less antagonistic so I guess you
know you're always going to get trolls
it's impossible to filter them out
entirely the problem is whether they
introduced too much noise to signal and
that's really all they have to
contribute is noise so all right fried
taters do you do it I think debt should
be heritable in a just society
definitely not and that is you know that
is one of the ways in which our
societies become worse and worse over
time there are types of debt that
spouses or children when a person dies
still gets stuck with and I don't think
that that should be transferable to them
but our corrupt legislators have given
the okay to that sort of thing mostly
because they're in the pockets of the
the people who service and collect and
produce that debt and I think that's
that's pretty disgusting the idea that
you know and you look at what it is
medical debt student loan debt the all
those sorts of things it's as if you
let's kick people who are down as much
as possible you know all right
Gai thoughts on Marxism Marx is you know
a thinker grounded in the classical
tradition who got introduced in the
Hegelian ISM of his time has some useful
ideas there's a million Wow there's not
a million I'm being hyperbolic there
there is hundreds of varieties of
Marxism right there's there's lots of
interpretations of him within the first
generation after his death they were
already multiple viewpoints on what what
constitutes Marxism so it's you know
there's a lot of great ideas and there's
a lot of like is with so many others a
lot of quite terrible ideas as well so
alright let's see what we've got
I'm putting a few
users into timeouts are wasting a lot of
space okay here's an interesting one
disciple of Rob what is the best
conception of God you've come across so
that's a good that's a good one I would
say that I like I like conceptions of
God where God is connected with the the
actual person who's trying to conceive
of them and where it complicates a
person's existence rather than to like
makes everything simpler and explains
everything and I have said this about
religion as well so yeah that's probably
the simplest way to say that oh it's an
interesting thing
Bojan are says AI has become meme at
this point in my opinion we know very
little next to nothing on consciousness
from the current materialist paradigm
that's true we have been singularly
unsuccessful in explaining consciousness
which all of us you know are intimately
familiar with and work through from
strictly materialist points of view and
yeah AI is much more of a human
construct than it is any sort of yeah
any sort of
what would we call it that's you know
reality that we can fully understand
through code I mean when it comes to
computer coding itself
we don't even know even the people who
do coding with the platforms that we're
using nobody nobody really has a full
idea of what's going on I mean it's kind
of funny it's sort of like a city
construction and people have just been
building on building on building on
building and after a while nobody nobody
knows where anything is so that's that's
I don't know there's a lot more to say
about that a lot more to think about
that but I'm gonna have to put that off
for right now because I don't have any
things that right right at hand all
right here's a question about social
media from MJ d'amore why do I seem more
aggressive on Twitter regarding politics
is contrasted with my temper tone with
philosophy thanks and sorry if that
comes off weird well because I think we
live in a time that's a time of crisis
you know I think that the Trump
administration is you know one of the
most corrupt that that I've seen in
American history and I and I do know
American history quite well I think that
many of the things that they are doing
and I think that the sort of spineless
giving into it on the part of other
Republicans is disgusting and I'm not
going to just sit here and pretend that
everything is a-okay and I'm you know
I'm an independent but I'll be voting
probably straight Democrat just because
I want his administered I want to make a
difference in getting them out and I've
also seen the same thing repeated in a
micro way here in Wisconsin where we had
an incredibly corrupt Republican
governor and we still have a Republican
dominated legislature because they
gerrymandered this state which is
apparently anti-democratic
so I mean why wouldn't I be aggressive
when it comes to politics
that's what Twitter's for Twitter is is
Twitter is a much looser format right so
yeah
Fujisan I have to do a Mino essay about
if Socrates is successful it is argument
about virtue of being knowledge I feel a
bit out of my depth any advice on how I
could approach this yeah so I mean if
you're just sticking with the Meno
Socrates ultimately says that that that
they're not successful in showing that
that virtue is knowledge right because
if it was knowledge then the virtuous
people of Athens ought to be able to
pass it on to their their kids or to
students or things like that so that's
towards the end of the the work there
are other places you know within the
Platonic corpus where the aquarias the
the not getting through points of things
like the Meno are satisfactorily
addressed so I would take a look at like
you know the Republic
fado is also good for discussing those
sorts of issues as well all right let's
see here principled uncertainty do I
think that our increasing awareness that
were possibly alone as intelligent
beings in the universe plus our loss of
faith is fueling our reliance on
politics to provide meaning I mean
politics has been providing meaning
forever
for human beings throughout recorded
history I don't know that you know
people talk about you know secular you
know secularization leading to
the displacement of what religion was
doing for people into other spheres like
politics or consumerism or art or things
like that I don't really buy that I
think that the the political impasses
that were in are politically driven you
know we have some some pretty major
issues facing us that we don't seem to
be able to deal with adequately I mean
one of them is climate change and you
know people can agree and disagree about
what model or stuff like that
interestingly the the conservative
institutions and people who you know
would normally poopoo it are preparing
now for for climate change you know sea
levels are gonna rise lots of real
estate is going to become unusable
people are figuring out what they're
gonna do for their portfolio that holds
that stuff right suddenly they go from
being deniers to being preparers the US
military definitely thinks climate
change is happening all you got to do is
live here in Wisconsin for a while and
you know climate change has happened and
you know there's debates about whether
we can do anything about it whether it's
man-made or not and all that and so
that's an issue and notice that we're
not able to form either as a nation here
in America or in the world
Renea we're not able to come together
and actually have a reasonable political
solution to this the massive growing
inequalities that we're seeing across
our society is another prime example as
well the debt crisis that were in
that you know led to a bubble in 2008 in
terms of housing debt but you know
there's other debt as well those are
those are political problems you know
the idea that we can't have national
health care
that instead we ought to have this this
stupid inefficient patchwork of you know
employer-provided healthcare or you know
state Medicaid systems where they can
opt-in and opt-out and and we leave
people mostly you know poor and
middle-class people in massive
insecurity and debt and oftentimes
people have been a bad medical outcomes
because of it because we need to keep
these insurance companies in existence
that's asinine you know that's a
political problem and it's it's bizarre
that we live in a time where one party
is totally against all that and they you
know
bragged about trying to defund or derail
or you know bring court cases to get rid
of Obamacare which was a really
milquetoast thing I mean we're on
Obamacare ourselves the ACA and let me
tell you it ain't free money you pay
into it and it's a real hassle to get
the the actual health care that you're
looking for lots of paperwork you know
ordinary people wouldn't find it very
easy to use and then you have another
party that's mostly focused on you know
talking points about that we should have
a very simple health care plan people
get health care you know and we find a
way to pay for it if we got to buy less
military equipment well let's have a
more rational foreign policy then but
we're not we're not we're not getting to
these things so you know these are all
political essentially political problems
in in Hana Arendt sense right we have to
live together they're not religious
problems you know and and I don't think
that they're they've become more acute
because less people are religious I
think they become more acute because now
we were confronted on an almost daily
basis with seeing the effects of that
social media has probably contributed to
that more than the loss of of faith so
alright let's see here
Tyco
Twitter by its restrictions becomes a
platform for emotional grunts not my
experience I don't know what sort of
experience you add of that
all right vintage watch guy was asking
uh asking somebody else about Lawrence
Thomas let's see what else we've got
scrolling down and Eric's
in a car --ss asks oh that's that's in
Portuguese I wonder if we have a
translation thing here no all right
YS Oh Bell conductor sailor do Freebird
I can't and I wouldn't want to cuz I'm
not a Skynyrd fan you know and free bird
for me sort of epitomizes Skynyrd never
been a Skynyrd fan frankly a lot a lot
of people that I know are but yeah it's
not I mean it's not a song that I've
ever wanted to learn so probably never
going to all right mr. big weak-kneed do
I think Islamic thinkers like avarosa
and Ovid sena should be read more off
and given their influence on the late
medieval period in the West yeah why not
the trouble is how are they gonna get
read more often you know who are we
gonna like if we're doing an intro to
philosophy class if we want to stick
them in who are we gonna take out so
that we can get them in and you know the
other issue is its I mean here so here
in Milwaukee if you actually want to
study that sort of stuff this is one of
the places to come to because just 12
blocks in that direction is Marquette
University which it houses the the
Aquinas and the Arabs project
run by Richard Taylor and there are
graduate students who are studying
Arabic and other languages so as to be
able to understand Islamic philosophy
that's one of the the real gems in our
academic philosophical landscape here in
Milwaukee but you know I don't know that
there's that many people who who are
going to be able to do that raid what do
I think of French postmodernists like
dari death who code to lose in
baudrillard I think some of them aren't
post modernists I think that leotard is
the one you're thinking of who writes
the postmodern condition and I think
they're they're all very interesting you
know they have they have contributions
to make and they're worth reading but I
wouldn't you know I wouldn't take any
one of them as like providing the way to
go about things I wouldn't ever become
like a delusion or a derp ideon or a
Foucauldian right a baudrillard e'en so
alright um let's see what else we have
here
Zeno of Elea
think about the book truth and Method I
just started it that's Hans gadamer all
right it's worth reading it's it's
interesting I like gadamer I like some
of his commentaries like on Hegel and
Plato it's kind of a slog oh but it's a
good book particularly in that it's sort
of like with Jameson right if you read
Jameson or you read gadamer mock sailors
like this - they make reference to so
many other people that you'll be like oh
I wonder what that person's saying so
you you end up having to learn some
other stuff along your way and I think
God was right about you know
interpretation is central to philosophy
you know there was this this attempt to
have got him ER and dairy debates at one
time and I don't think all that much
came of it but they were saying you know
do you think of it like dairy at the
time it was now kind of old hat but
dairy dad was like this you know
everything is you know attacks can be
deconstructed and all that and gadamer
was saying something similar but he's
saying it much more palatable language
so it's all interpretation in one way or
another we're all we all have some sort
of prejudging going on I think you know
those are those are good insights Steven
Warren was start missing something when
in response to heidegger's being towards
death he said that death was outside of
his possibilities no I don't think so
you know try to conceptualize your own
death think about whether whether it's
like your possibility or whether it's
the possibility that you won't be around
for you know Michael Davis do I know of
any important philosophical works that
have not yet been translated into
English there's lots of them there's
plenty of philosophical works
that are worth reading that have not
been translated into English you know
the guy wrote my dissertation on Maurice
blowing dough he he wrote a trilogy
towards the end of his life which was
actually five volumes
none of that stuff has been translated
his philosophical demands of
Christianity has recently been
translated by Oliver Platt and I know
Lex I actually I had to review it for
the press but his his book on on
mysticism never translated his book 1932
about Christian philosophy never been
translated lots and lots of stuff plenty
of articles that he wrote through that
haven't been translated and that's just
one thinker out of so many you know
there is there's this this vicious cycle
that occurs when somebody doesn't get
translated then people assume that it
must not be important so they don't
bother to read it and then there's less
interest in it and then of course it
remains untranslated so it doesn't get
read so it doesn't get translated so it
doesn't get read and this is this is the
case
Jerry very often so yeah there's lots of
important works that haven't been
translated into English all right t
gains how does Heidegger's concept of
metaphysics differ from other
philosophers there are lots of different
conceptions from metaphysics right
because there's many many philosophers
out there
Heidegger has what here's an easy way to
answer this Heidegger he has this what
he calls epical hit you know sort of
viewpoint on metaphysics which is that
you've got you got beings things that
are and then there's capital be being
and throughout the history of
metaphysics which is what Heidegger
wants to undo
some range of being beings have been
taken as being capital B being these
beings are like the revelatory thing so
Plato you know is one example of that
Aristotle's another Christianity
Heidegger thinks is another and then you
get you know Descartes and you get the
modern scientific scientific materialism
each of these represents a metaphysics
that is revelatory of being in some way
but also deficient in others reductive
Heidegger wants to undo that and have a
you know a more adequate metaphysics on
his own
so that's I guess that's a good way to
put it
let's see here what is the best moral
system virtue ethics but a real virtue
ethics not not some you know anemic
reconstruction of Aristotle that leaves
out the most interesting bits and tries
to argue in a sort of analytic
philosophy way but actual actual virtue
ethics you know what Alastair MacIntyre
calls a tradition constituted
rationality which means that virtue
ethics will not remain just for a true
ethics but will also take on the best
insights from dant illogical
perspectives or utilitarian perspectives
or Alistair McIntyre was a Marxist
Marxist perspectives and will
incorporate that into one thing that's
the best moral system all right um let's
is a lot of back and forth
says when Hegel writes about
consciousness he writes about miserable
consciousness so do you think that to
live conscious life means to be unhappy
or not necessarily so let's correct that
from the beginning Hegel does talk about
the unhappy consciousness right but the
would sign the word for consciousness
there is not only used in that section
it's used throughout the entire
phenomenology so you know to focus only
on the unhappy consciousness is being
consciousness itself would be a bit of a
mistake just as much as when people like
think that the phenomenology is
basically the master-slave dialectic
amend a bunch of other stuff after it
there there have been people like eric
lee has an entire book on Hegel's
unhappy consciousness which I don't know
I don't know if that one's been
translated to English I suspect it
probably has because Erica is fairly
well known but maybe it hasn't but no
there's nothing inherently unhappy or
glueck leak about about consciousness
for Hegel you can say that you know
consciousness very often is not entirely
satisfied all right because
consciousness is desire or hunger geared
up and not just in the self
consciousness section but throughout the
entire phenomenology but there are many
places where consciousness is quite
happy with itself perhaps too happy with
itself right so yeah let's see a lot of
discussion about Peter standing back and
forth here kind of a waste of time I
think his cultural moment has
sufficiently passed Marty rates I think
he's asking questions that were asked in
this chatroom like 20 minutes ago really
doing one by one that's what we do in
this that's always been what I do in
this so you know
you wanna like I put in all my social
media you want to get your question
answered get it in early because they
you can see lots of people ask a lot of
questions for this and why wouldn't I go
one by one that's that's a fair thing to
do people will get their questions in
early you know they get their questions
answered first all right
fried taters academia and the rest of
the cathedral is coming down well it's
interesting that you're using because
the cathedral because you just can't
outed yourself as a neo reactionary a
mold bug person there who basically is a
reincarnated version of the leader of
axial France as Charl Murat as far as I
can tell a lot of these ideas are not
radically new anti-car sis says de Boden
and neo Stoics like big leader like
peterson to philosophy for non
philosophers for dummies ethical
oriented so I wouldn't I wouldn't lump
Alain de Botton
and Massimo Pigliucci in the same thing
and I wouldn't use the term neo stoic
because that actually has a proper use
for the Christian Stoics of the 16th
century the proper term is modern stoic
right
and while Alain de Botton maybe like
Peterson I think he's they're both
rather shallow I wouldn't say that about
pigley og as a matter of fact he's a
colleague of mine and I think that it's
important to do philosophy for non
philosophers and to have an ethical
orientation the question is whether
you're gonna do it well or do it poorly
Massimo you know his foray into stoicism
is relatively new he started a blog
called I think how to be a stoic or
something like that
and he was sort of experimenting with it
for
you know a good amount of time this is
interacted with other people who were
who are quite interested in it and his
works are as far as I can see you know
on points when it comes to that so you
know there's no lack of rigor there
whereas I would say and about butts on
and Peter so there definitely is all
right let's see else we have Nathan
Wagga sir good good question here is is
Einar and a legitimate philosopher yeah
I mean she studied philosophy
she writes philosophy it's just it just
so happens that her philosophy isn't
particularly good and that when it comes
to the history of philosophy she is not
to be trusted at all you know but
there's plenty of people within the
history of philosophy who are not good
philosophers people often mistake being
a philosopher with being a good
philosopher and they're not the same
thing the same concept right and there
are there aren't you know quite a few
people that that are making something
out of ran that's quite interesting but
it's sort of like deciding that you're
gonna plow your field with a tractor
from the 1920s when you you could
actually have you know better technology
and get it get the job done more
effectively you can only get so much out
of it right but there's a there's a good
book on Rand and virtue ethics that came
out back in the early part of the 21st
century so Sally Field thoughts on
Vidkun Stein's quote the limits of my
language means the limits of my world I
think it's a nice sound bite but I think
it's not true at all and I think they
can shine himself you know recognize
that over time as well
all right um look just jumped again
let's see it we got here scroll back up
try to avoid here we go
Anna car [ __ ] asks what I'm thinking
about your rod Kim Yuna's revolution and
analytic philosophy I don't have any
clue at all I don't really follow much
any analytic philosophy gede 570 I'm
considering getting a higher degree in
philosophy but I'm honestly intimidated
by the competition within the field in
terms of getting a job do you have any
advice it's a terrible job market it's
going to remain a terrible job market if
you're gonna try to do it get yourself
some other marketable skills so that you
know after you've put in all the time to
get a PhD and you don't you don't get a
tenure track job many of which are going
away right away you can still feed
yourself and anybody else that you're
responsible for and realize that we're
in a very different kind of market now
you know the the time in the 1960s
through 80s when you could just get
yourself a philosophy degree and there
were actually almost as many jobs as
there were people getting degrees that
that ended you know generations ago I
would say the other thing is if you're
hell-bent on trying to get a falafel
Asif II job go to the highest tier
school that you can get into and afford
because although people at higher tier
institutions are not any better or
smarter than the rest of us prestige
really does run the show when it comes
to academic philosophy oswald spengler
racism you read Bernard Charbonneau I
not [ __ ] are what do I think of
Daniel Dennett and scientism and in
general I think scientism is in this
mistake I think that for many people
it's a emotional substitute for whatever
it was that they wanted to get out of
something else if it's not going to be
religion it may as well be scientism and
I think the way that they behave you
know bears that out so Dennett not
particularly interested in him ah fried
taters who or what sparked my interest
in philosophy so I can say that I've
always been interested in understanding
how things are connected with each other
and I've always been interested in
ethical questions and that goes all the
way back to being a kid
for example one of my earliest memories
is of being living here in in Wisconsin
in specifically Thiensville was a suburb
of Milwaukee and I was probably about
four years old
then I was playing with an
african-american kid in a sandbox on a
playground and whoever my babysitter was
I remember her pulling me away by my
wrist and being very upset and saying
you don't play with them and I was like
what do you mean them and she's like
black kids and and I said well why not
and she couldn't answer and she's just
dragging me along and I remember you
know vaguely telling my parents about it
and I'm getting upset because my family
it was you know it certainly my dad
especially consistently anti-racist and
so you know questions about that sort of
thing why this arbitrary you know
distinction that's a philosophical
question as well as as well as you know
you could say a political question and
other questions as well and you know I
was always interested in the nature of
the universe and as soon as I discovered
I didn't discover my dad taught me
mathematics and he started when I was
four you know I learned addition and
subtraction and multiplication and
division and then we started moving into
other things which kind of created
problems for me when I went to school
because I was beyond where the class was
I was interested in the nature of things
and I you know I had people along the
way who would give me books or guidance
or stuff like that that were helpful
I've mentioned in one of my videos a
teacher that I had in high school mr.
Lorenzo who played a really important
role he taught a sacraments class that
he essentially taught as a philosophy
class oriented around Plato Aristotle
and Augustine and I took a philosophy
class in high school it was absolute
garbage where we use the wise of a
philosophical Scrivener as our textbook
and the teacher taught in a very dry
dolloway so those you know those those
were things that sparked my interest but
I was always interested in these these
sort of questions polygraph how to
distinguish between the Philosopher's
and the philosophy expert I suppose
you'd have to ask them you know these
are not terms that I would try to
introduce a very rigid distinction about
but you will meet some people who will
say listen I'm not a philosopher and the
historian of philosophy or I'm not a
philosopher I'm just somebody who
teaches this sort of thing but you know
if you think about a clap more classical
conceptions of philosophy philosophy was
always engaged with life it was never an
academic subject studied only for its
own sake the way it often is now it was
supposed to be you know a way of living
rationally so I would say that that's
part of it oh here's a great question
from Abdul
why is Lacan write like that in the
a Cree so like that means like a pompous
name dropping pain-in-the-ass
making it complicated for its own sake
kind of person well on part cos Lacan
was that kind of person to begin with
and in part because many of the ickey
are the things where he's sort of like
sticking it to the establishment and
showing them how dumb they are and how
smart he is and in part because he could
get away with it oh yeah that's that's
all part of it and sometimes it's
actually demanded by it by the subject
matter he's trying to make a point to
try to get us to think about something
but I would say at least half of the
time Lacan is being unnecessarily
difficult right so that that's that's
part of it all right it's 134 we're a
little bit over time here so I'm gonna
just jump around a bit and take some
easy questions and bring it to a close
around 140 Central Time
Nathan asks a question that I've got a
really easy answer to what do I think is
the best order to read philosophy should
one read in historical order or is it
all right to decide based on interest
it's totally all right to decide based
on interest you're gonna have to reread
the stuff that you're reading anyway and
maybe the next time around you decide to
read it in chronological order but there
there isn't any absolute order that you
have to do things in all right
do I think full
Oscar's working on the history of
philosophy can make original
contributions to modern analytic and
other philosophy using older categories
to resolve issues in the analytic and
other philosophy yeah they can I don't
know if they want to you know analytic
philosophers the bed that they've made
they can sleep in it you know there's
enough other stuff to do that we don't
need to help them out
all right um let's see what else we've
got here Kyle do I think an atheist can
ascribe to a de ontological school of
thought sure yeah you could be like a
traditional humanist atheist and like
totally buy into Conte and you know
that's de ontology you could be an
intuitionist like like Ross and some guy
who's still alive Robert Audi right I
don't see where that has you know it has
to have a legend sort of religious
connection so there's all sorts of ways
you could do that
Quinn Pascal this chest off think we'd
be better off without the Greeks no I
mean it's not even an option to begin
with and the Greeks have interesting
things to say he just thinks that they
they got some things wrong and modern
philosophy followed them down that way
all right let's see here I can zo what I
returned in each's Arthur stir and go
through the rest of the book yeah if I
have the time eventually in core
concepts I probably will I only need the
first part for my classes because we
that's really all we get a chance to
read but yeah down down the line Troy
Miller who do you recommend to read for
American for
ah see so you know we usually think of
American philosophy in terms of
pragmatism and people usually think
first James Dewey right definitely you
should read Charles Sanders purse
definitely read William James Dewey you
can read if you want to I'm not that big
of a fan of him I think it's good to
read George Santayana who is also their
contemporary and Josiah Royce but we
should also kind of like go backwards a
better right
who else is important in American
philosophy Jonathan Edwards who's doing
an interesting thing of trying to think
through Locke and think through
Calvinism at the same time it has a lot
of cool stuff to say about the will and
its freedom or lack thereof and about
the affections the transcendentalists
they're quite important as well and then
you know you have all of these sort of
more minor figures along the way that
often have some some you know political
involvement that are that are worth
checking out as well let's see getting
close to the end to do
oh yeah this is a good one to go out on
do I have an opinion on Robert Brandon
or other recent analytic work on Hegel
yeah I like Brandon Brandon is a great
example of an analytic philosopher of
history who gets things right because he
does the work of actually reading the
text and thinking about them and in the
process ceases to be an analytic
philosopher and becomes a history of
philosophy person when you read his
works you're often struck by how how
little it bears resemblance to
contemporary analytic philosophy and
that's because of the effect of actually
reading texts you know if you are gonna
work on Hegel and you don't read widely
you're not working on Hegel you're
working on your little sliver even with
Descartes right you look at Harry
Frankfort another great example
Harry Frankfort does some really
interesting stuff you if you know him
you know him most likely because of the
notion of second order desires but he
died on in his career he talks about
this a necessity volition of love he
actually decided to work on Descartes
and the reason he did is he said well
the carts got a small corpus I won't
have to read that much but he did read
all the stuff and he has some really
interesting and insightful things to say
about it and he uses those things later
on and again in the process effectively
ceases being an analytic philosopher
because he's not following their typical
shtick so that's a good thing to go out
on got some got a lot of questions I
didn't get to but you know that's always
the case here we'll have some other
things coming up later on in the month
probably do some philosophy pop ups
I haven't cited the thing yet but now I
got to get to setting up things for my
classes that begin Monday at Milwaukee
Institute of Art Design so thanks
everybody for tuning in and we're
you happen to be happy that you were
able to come in looks like there were
quite a bit of trolls but I managed to
silence them after a while so that's
unfortunately what happens with these
sorts of things there's always going to
be a fly in the ointment doesn't there
so whether it's afternoon like it is
here or morning or night hope that you
have a good one and I'll see you
somewhere else in the ether